[Musique]
abonnement piégé vol d'identité
hameçonnage la technologie omniprésente
dans notre quotidien
fais nous une cible facile pour des
fraudeurs partout autour du globe
il suffit qu'une mince portion des gens
visés tombent dans le panneau pour que
ce soit payant pour les fraudeurs 100
millions de dollars c'est le montant
soutirer aux victimes de fraude l'an
dernier au canada et la fraude qui a
coûté le plus cher aux canadiens est
sans contredit la fraude sentimentale
loin d'être nouvelle
elle fait encore chaque année de
nombreuses victimes le fraudeur gagne la
confiance et l'affection de sa victime
dans le but de lui soutirer de l'argent
encore cette année au niveau des pertes
signalé c'était de loin de la plus
importante l'an dernier on comptait plus
ou moins 1000 victimes pays et les
pertes déclarées dépasse 22 millions de
dollars la fraude sentimentale est quand
même assez dérangeant parce que ça joue
aussi avec les sentiments des personnes
lamotte éléphants dit qu'il est de l'
agence du revenu du canada
la fraude de revenu canada continue de
faire des ravages des millions de
canadiens ont reçu un appel ou un texto
leur disant qu'il devait de l'argent à
l' agence du revenu du canada l'an
dernier les fraudeurs ont soutiré plus
de 6 millions de dollars à leurs
victimes et non avec la venue des
technologies développement des
technologies des fraudeurs accès un plus
grand bassin d'apporter des victimes
potentielles et les fraudeurs vont aller
vers vous c'est payant les stratégies
utilisées par les fraudeurs se
multiplient le conseil du centre
antifraude redoubler de vigilance et
prudence
mais malgré tout les nouvelles
technologies font en sorte que personne
n'est à l'abri avant on voyait des
courriels d'hameçonnage qui avait des
photographes
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus réaliste
et même quand on reçoit un texto avec un
hyperlien dedans si on clique dessus ce
qu'on pensait jamais trop on peut voir
que les sites d'un saut financières sont
vraiment semblable aux réussites et
c'est souvent à s'y méprendre les
fondeurs ont tenté de voler des données
de cartes de crédit à partir de bases de
données sécurisées et lavande
ou sinon utiliser ces cartes de crédit à
l'insu des consommateurs pour une 15e
année le mois de mars est destiné à la
prévention de la fraude
et ce à travers le pays ici qui me
permettra au canada montréal